i've been trying to figure out how to
tell you that
i want to spend the rest of my life with
you
this is complete horse
that's because you're doing it wrong oh
yeah yeah
you got to get your hips into it like
this
you're kind of full of it you know that
am i or am i awesome at it
thanks for the thanks for the beer yeah
i'm around anytime you need to talk
all right yeah
[Music]
i'm so sorry no i'm
nah hey it's okay
[Music]
adam
hey hey
i um
i came here to apologize to you
okay so i'm sorry
you're a really good cop
and you are gonna get your shot again
soon
they came all the way here just to tell
me that
i like you
i know you know that and i miss you
[Music]
i wanted to keep this informal so i
thought you know what's more formal than
the uh
locker room
right
okay
so listen i know i've been a little
weird lately it's got nothing to do with
you and i working together i just uh
been trying to figure out how to tell
you that
i want to spend the rest of my life with
you
and uh you and i are freaking awesome
together i know this is quick but i
don't care cause i love you yes
[Music]
my dad can't make it tonight he's gonna
work violence reduction no when did you
find that out he just called you know
how it is with those shifts that just
pop up did you tell them that my mom's
like only in town one year yeah i know
he's really sorry
huh
what
all week
we've been talking about this for a
month
well maybe i mean
you and i both know what it's like with
overtime bob can't pass that up you know
hey listen we'll talk about this later
just would you tell your mom that we're
both really really sorry just tell her
that
i gotta go okay
[Music]
i'm not gonna say anything
hey
everyone's going to molly's meet up with
some of the fire cats from 51 you want
to go
i don't think so
no
what's going on you okay
you were never gonna meet my mom were
you
so afraid if you did the wedding would
become real
come on
hey where's this coming from
it's fine
i accept it now
you don't want to be along
i am letting you off
kim
hey
yeah
would you want to come with me
what my nephew just saw back to the
future for the first time so he's been
trying to skateboard behind cars all
week long
i love that kid my sister got a little
more than she bargained for with
him i'm pregnant
what
yeah the um doctor she ran some tests
while i was getting stitched up this
morning now
i am
pregnant
is it yes
from the night after after that night
okay
you sure that i don't need this
okay sorry i'm sure
uh-huh
yeah okay what do you want to do
or no adam what do you want to do i
don't know i'm kind of playing ketchup
over here um
i mean do you want a kid i know that
when we were together you said you
wanted kids
i do want kids
someday
right
okay well listen
you know whatever you decide i'm gonna
be there and i'll support you
oh that was a tough
day yes bit of a tough day
i don't want you to be alone in all of
this i think you should let me drive you
to the appointment in the morning yes
not necessary well i know that you're a
strong independent woman and all that
but i care about you and i want to be
there for you i bet miss baby would be
so hard adam i'm not trying to influence
you either way yeah i'll be finished
then
maybe it's selfish of me with
this job and
being single but
i don't want to miss the opportunity to
be a mom
and i don't
want to make a decision i might regret
okay what does that mean
i don't know what it means
other than i
i canceled the appointment
okay all right
and be okay
[Music]
okay all
no i don't right
[Music]
yes i heard
we'll be right here kim
still right here
[Music]
thanks for coming we said it was urgent
so
there you're child cutting
it's my former shower garden yeah
hmm
michaela's asleep do you mind if we
talk out here not at all what's going on
okay yeah yeah um
i'm naming you as my custodian
in the adoption
like if anything happens to me you're
the one who's gonna take care of him
kayla
uh i'm a little confused i mean you
remember what's been going on the
questions you've had about me i mean
things haven't been too good between us
i know
okay so is it about that or is it about
this case what went down no it's not
about either okay why would you do that
dad because we're supposed to have a
baby together dummy
because we're family
because
you and i are
a lot of things
including pretty screwed up
who knows if we'll ever really get our
act together but
our last name is burgess now adam
and um
one thing that we can be
you and i is
is we can be this
whole big round thing that can surround
and protect her
you know even if michaela doesn't know
it exists
and i need that
it's the only way that i can do this
be a good mom and be the kind of cop
that i need to be
i need
obviously you can say no but i'm could
you just think about it i don't even
think about it
it's a guess of course
i'm honored that you'd ask me
but i won't
i will
i'll look inside where treasures hide
if you don't think some people do
some people will have no use for you
but i will
i will
our thoughts will play and stay all day
hey
[Music]
you